moi je suis aux alentours de 500 mille
euros par part sérieusement c'est dans
ces critères là bravo et c'est maxime ou
quartier la voie du sommaire c'est un
cadeau qu'on lui faisait 16 où l'on
mettra une nouvelle voie sur le sommaire
vous déciderez voilà derrière ça peut
être le rire mathias à jour aujourd'hui
je suis très très content mais voilà
donc qui peut avoir plein de choses
comme ça ça va être une voix une
d'arkham merci d'être avec nous les 10
927 on est en direct et les chéris il va
passer plein de choses dans l'émission
que vous avez pu le voir et ils sont
avec nous pas garé là merci pas garde
est là
et gérard hernandez j'étais avec lui
aussi qu'on aime le jazz
gérard hernandez de l'aviation et qui
vient nous voir pour les schtroumpfs et
oui quand même souhaité un schtroumpf
versèrent à ce petit bonhomme que j'ai
connue dans le ventre de sa mère voulait
qu'au niveau de ventes de sa mère oui
oui et après j'ai vu grand pays
il avait peur il se cacher quand on est
mignon comme tout mais alors pas gars tu
me connais saga autant dans la vie
oui c'est vrai qui connais pas gaston de
la table voyant qu'il connaît bien le
benjamin
oui bon on a vu on a vu enfin je connais
oui suivre les marseillais de deux
manières à s'éloigner mais ça fait quand
même plusieurs années qu'il est là donc
évidemment qu'on le connaît sur les
personnages phares des marseillais ça
fait combien d'années que vous faites
les marseillais 5 en septembre
57 les marseillais c'est quoi les
critères pour être sélectionné dans les
marseillais un mois c'est pour moi
c'était d'essayer marseillais bien avant
l'accord notamment mais c'était un peu
du hasard pour moi ah oui c'est vrai que
moi j'ai passé le casting la dernière
minute j'ai un peu fait rigoler la
productrice et on m'a dit banco vas-y
pas garde par à miami en tant que didier
j'étais là mais vous êtes dj alors vous
voulez faire quoi en fait dit j'ai un
peu tout moi
commerce combien vous êtes payé pour une
saison des marseillais à peu près comme
toi mais tu divises par ami don
[Rires]
mattingly normalement vous êtes payés
entre 7000 et 12000 euros selon
l'ancienneté de votre participation
minime un produit cette nuit l'euro ou
du filet pour toute la saison
la productrice ça aurait indiqué à bien
indiqué ces déchets chiffre entre 7000
et 12000 euros pour toute la saison
salut roumain de saison ça fait cinq
saisons que je fais enfin cinq ans donc
j'ai fait à peu près 10 16 ans ouais
mais bon j'arrive toujours en cours où
je pars avant donc d'accord plus ou
moins on va dire que ça fait comment ça
le prit alors le prix à la fourchette
tout dépend en fait tout dépend vraiment
vous êtes bon ton peut apporter
vous vous êtes bon et moi je suis aux
alentours de 500 mille euros par an
sérieusement c'est dans ces critères là
bravo bravo bravo m'attire j'ai pas
envie de parler au maximum ils attendent
on va venir ce qui s'y passe à la télé
et on va revenir bien sûr dans un
instant sur ce qui a marqué 1 les
marseillais c'est cette histoire avec
votre votre compagne on va arriver on va
y revenir vous allez voir dans les même
lui ne va pas être bien du tout je vous
le dis